a video features an interview with
Michelle Clapton British costume
designer who already won an Emmy Award
for the costumes in Game of Thrones in
2012 however video beside including
sketches of costumes also includes many
main characters as well as a few minor
characters while the same video has also
once again confirmed an appearance of a
new character in this video we can see a
wide variety of characters either
messing around preparing for the
shooting or actually filming scenes we
can see John snow in winter foul on
Dragonstone
well Daenerys is the whole time in
Dragonstone either in the main hall
beside the painted table or is setting
on her new throne there is one very
interesting group shot in Winterfell
that includes Jon Snow sense a stark
brilliant torment and other lords which
is not that exciting but the same shot
once again confer an appearance of a
Lascar Stark in the upcoming season as
we can see an actress Megan Parkinson on
the right side appearance a phallus
Karstark in the upcoming season is not
that surprising at all since parkinson's
agency has actually already confirmed
her appearance in the seventh season of
Game of Thrones a few months ago Ellis
Karstark is daughter of Rickard Karstark
and is an heir of house Karstark since
her father and two brothers died a long
time ago while her only remaining
brother Harold who back in the sixth
season was head of house Karstark will
either be executed or sent to the wall
for his betrayal over House Stark Harold
led the cavalry charge in Jon Snow in
the Battle of the bastards and this
meeting that includes all Norton Lords
as well as Ellis Karstark herself will
the term fit of her house we also see
Cersei Lannister and later Jamie as well
standing on a massive map of Westeros as
it had almost been finished perhaps the
most interesting shot to us would be
similarly in Sarah Dell who is seemingly
clearing a dust from its shelves while
is either looking for an old book that
has not been read by anyone in a long
time or is simply maintaining the
library there's also a shot of Tyrion
walking on a beach of privilege
Dragonstone as he will land over there
with Daenerys
but it could also be in King's Landing
as he will go over there with Davos in
order to find and escort ginjury to
Dragonstone we can also see Theon
tormund Littlefinger Davos brianandleigh
a novel
it said there are many shots effectors
just messing around set there are also a
few shot safari mounted on horse
probably heading home but at the time is
most likely still in Riverlands